let's go to our caller from the seven
one eight area code who's calling today
from seven one eight hey Greg from New
York first-time caller hey Greg what's
up I'm called yourself a libertarian I
think on some level you know I'm sort of
more on the libertarian side a little
more skeptical of the government
institutions including police and I just
wanted to say a lot of the progressive
hosts are sort of coming around to the
conversation that libertarians have been
having okay let me stop you right there
Greg though because I need to issue a
huge disclaimer when I say I'm a left
libertarian I mean I'm saying small-l
libertarian right so if we imagine a
spectrum of authoritarianism and
libertarianism these are lowercase I
my instinct is I want to be more on the
libertarian side unless there's a
compelling reason to regulator to
involve government so I am not at all
like not at all a capital L libertarian
I just mean that on issues of
authoritarianism versus libertarianism I
tend to lean towards the Liberty low
little L libertarianism unless there's a
compelling reason not to write I think
I'm the same way okay and I just wanted
to push you a little bit on with my
skepticism of the government sure right
so for example just in the last few
months we've had everyone from the waho
that the CDC Surgeon General including
Falchi and including pence saying don't
wear masks and I believe that that was a
mistake that led to the lock downs which
were supposed to be a last resort the
economic damage done from that and
people out of work now contributed to
these giant protests which of course the
police you know this has been going on
for years with the Ferguson protests and
then we had the Baltimore this has been
going on you know I am very skeptical of
having these authorities tell us don't
wear masks and then later saying yeah
you should wear masks and just
yesterday's w-h-o retracted what they
said which was that um Oh asymptomatic
people don't you don't spread the virus
but then they kind of walked it
you want why are we listening as regular
people who are living in the world why
don't we take things into our own hands
put things to put things into the
lobbies of buildings and solve it on a
private level okay so there's a couple
different guns going on here that are
interesting first of all you're rightly
pointing out that there have been
misunderstandings about the virus those
misunderstandings are not inherent to
government agencies necessarily in other
words lots of people you also had you
know people that had nothing to do with
government saying we weren't gonna have
any cases by the end of April they had
nothing to do with government they were
also very very wrong so that part you do
you agree with that that there were
there were all sorts of things that were
incorrect about the corona virus from
industry from private citizens from
government agencies from health
organizations a lot of people got a lot
of things wrong you agree oh absolutely
many people get things wrong but when
you centralize the decision-making in
the hands of a few people that are wrong
that's when it gets really bad well my
argument would be that it's a
contradiction that you are on the one
hand asserting your skepticism of
government power while at the same time
saying most of the mistakes were not
doing enough so a lot of libertarians if
presented with the mandate from
government very early for everybody to
wear masks would have said I don't want
that that's too much power the
government can't tell me to wear a mask
so I want you to think about that
contradiction you're saying you're
skeptical of government authority but
you're saying they weren't strict enough
but wouldn't you have been saying who
are they to tell me to wear a mask if
they had said that right away well to be
clear I think there will be government
so anyway whether okay but that wasn't
my comment but that was in my question
Greg right well to answer your question
directly I'm saying that because we're
accustomed to listening to certain
authorities right word authority would
imply that they have the authority in
the knowledge of it also the fact that
we're comin to this versus let's say in
science or the English language and so
on I think that that we have to be very
careful when with the messaging
coming out from whu-oh differ well and
and that's important too how are you
gonna put in filter so it doesn't happen
next time well so so I I agree with you
we have to this was a disaster on all
levels we have to have a better you know
more more well-functioning system the
pandemic response team never should have
been abandoned the pandemic response
PlayBook that was left behind for Trump
should have been followed but remember
we Trump didn't listen to the WH o on a
lot of stuff so at least in the United
States you said you're in New York a lot
of what went wrong here doesn't really
have as much to do with the United
States show we have a government here
that was led by an incompetent buffoon
so I don't want to put the focus too
much on the WH o even though I agree
with your critiques Greg last thing I
just wanted to say look I live in New
York and just look at the sense of
proportion the NYPD is the seventh
largest army in the world by number of
people yet operate across several
continents with the war on terror and
expanded budget
why not when I say defund right people I
think that's the wrong word many people
say you know disinvest or reduce the
budget yeah the budget of the DoD that
can't account for seven trillion dollars
I mean at what point do we finally say
look conservatives we agree with you
let's start cutting and we will start
with DoD and the police force and give
the hospitals give to you know schools
why not yeah I I think one thing that
has been very much missing from this
entire discussion is we talked about
defunding and demilitarizing the police
what about defunding and demilitarizing
the military which is very rarely being
discussed right now and you know you
there's much more of a debate as to what
police departments are doing for us then
what fifty bases in germany are doing
for us and i would like I would like to
see that be a bigger part of the
discussion thank you all right so that's
I just want to end with the word of
kudos
you know there's a lot of people that
don't embrace allies you know across
libertarians or conservatives and you
David I think are out to talk about the
truth and stick to actually fact and I
think there's a lot of hope if everybody
did that I think we could find a lot of
common ground
all right Gregg thank you very much
appreciate the phone call and the kind
words that's going to do it for calls
today sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody but I do appreciate so many
people wanting to call in we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this